and they go up against brady singer
for the first time that's right brady
singer he is going to be on the attack i
guarantee you
gallo on the ground and through
for a base hit so kenner falefa stops at
second the rangers have two hits in the
inning a couple of base runners here
setting up again
so you know they're going to keep an eye
on him at second base and seeing
looking his hands doing some drills yeah
like i said
you better be hacking or you'll get rung
up anything close
jordan lyle's working pretty quickly
here as we take a look at his
2020 season we know that it was not a
particularly strong one
for jordan and the era was up over seven
he talked about it quite a bit
and he was honestly obviously hard to
run from that fact strikeouts were down
so santana is aboard one on two out to
salvador perez
the breaking ball rolled to third base
holt will go the short way to take care
of santana
and the inning is done so a scoreless
top
and bottom of the first in kansas city
what is going on
in the second inning no score jorge
solaire
first step and then if we notice any
kind of metrics difference there's a
good look at one right there
looks like that might have been a slider
for a swing and a miss
that one went straight down first strike
out of the day
[Applause]
isabelle left-handed batter where's the
number 28.
squares to bunt lays down a bunt out in
front of the plate it's time and he
drops it
had time to get him but maybe hurrying a
bit
and jonah heim just dropped it
i think i heard them say base hit but
that's an error on the catcher that is
not a base hit that bunt was about two
feet in front of home plate it was not a
good bun
there goes isbell a breaking ball so a
good pitch to run on and he got a big
jump
he wanted to run the pitch before that's
his first big league stolen base it's
the royals
first stolen base excellent takeoff
watch him
he's he's at full speed in two steps
love that another
royal that can steal bases close
but he didn't want to push it there's a
swing and a miss so
looks like maybe the the slider were a
change up that time
but he gets alberto and the inning is
done
well the inning continues so the good
news there is that dahl by
hustling that out he he gets gallowed to
the plate
with a runner on in front of him
this one up the middle and that was
scalded for a base hit he's two for two
today
wow look out
so a couple of men out there for nate
lowe singers first
three ball count of the day in his 45th
pitch
is belted out toward right field
carrying toward the fountains it is
gone wow a splashdown out of those
fountains
monstrous home run for nate lowe and
once again the rangers strike
first it's three nothing right on time
as you were talking about the power
that nate lowe has in that bat what he
had seen from him what we have seen so
far is
line drives the other way but picking a
spot when he could actually let it fly a
little bit and he did and brady singer
went back to the slider again kind of
surprising
the royals with murrayfield was stepped
to the plate
wit drives it to left field that's his
sixth hit of the series
he'll be at second base with one out
two strike offering and a swing and a
miss
third strikeout for lyles this afternoon
two gone
santana a sharp single to write his
first time up
there's a fastball swing and a miss and
santana is out on strikes
so for lyle's four punch outs here in
the early going
a cow needs to come talk to him and see
if they can help him somehow someway
man he's off singer he's having a hard
time finding the strike zone right now
it's a walk that loads him up here with
one out
so a big rbi opportunity here for isaiah
keiner philippa
well he goes after that one and sneaks
it through the left side of the infield
holt is in
heim on the way throws off line and now
heading to third base tavares
and kiner falefa able to advance a bag
as well on the air and throw
two run score it's five nothing kind of
send that message if nothing else david
dahl
hits this one high in the air out to
right field should be deep enough to get
home another run
isbell makes the catch and leota able to
score easily from third
six nothing rangers lyles
pitches the first few innings west
benjamin will follow him and there is
strike three called he gets isabelle
looking
fifth strikeout today this looks like
the curveball from jordan lyles
a very nice one you see how it finishes
at the bottom of the zone 80 miles an
hour
started nearly at the top that's really
good breaking
jordan's first appearance of the regular
season had a good spring
smart move and he got him swinging
but he went right after him in the zone
and the inning is done
what a start for jordan lyles five
shutout in kansas city
i'm still shy of 60 pitches for the day
this ball roped into right field
heim with a base hit takes an aggressive
turn and he'll have an
easy double jonah heims first hit as a
ranger
zimmer has a scoreless sixth inning
working around the lead-off double
has been mowing down the royals with
five scoreless innings he is only
allowed
three hits
beautiful punt so the royals have their
lead off man on for the first time and
let's see if they can turn that into
something bentendi is one for three
payoff pitch strike three called
santana down looking and yet another
strikeout
for jordan lyles today number seven
here is salvador perez he's over two
salvi hits it to center field the wind
will push it
and that ball is gone for a two run home
run
fans were waiting for salvador perez to
check in and
maybe on the day they gave him his
silver bat award and his
comeback player of the year award he
says i got to do something that's a
four-seam fastball
and i was just getting ready to say one
bad pitch
the royals to take advantage of it they
can get right back in this game and sure
enough here they come
shimmer gives up his first walk one on
one out
that the royals would be the team
picking him up right
zimmer has three scoreless innings
he gets the double play to put an end to
the top of the eight the royals are down
to their last
six outs on offense and they trail by
four outstanding work
back to the top for kinder philippa
want to get away commercial well that
ball left up and kind of for left it
takes a pretty good hack
carrying deep out there to left it's
gone
and kinder philippa takes one over the
wall for a solo
shot of the nine first home run of the
year and it completes a really good day
at the plate for ikf
off the baseball field
but the rules change out there that's to
the gap
and it's going to drop and there was
some confusion out there
answer alberto ends up at second base
with a double
taylor scores it's 7-3
[Applause]
could use one more
and he gets it the high fastball right
past mcgroom and this one is over
the rangers at long last in the win
column this year